You say in the book that
an actor can own a line,
and after he says that nobody else
can really ever say it again.
Yeah, your line is and I'd rather
have you say it than May.
Prof. Yes, exactly.
How did that come about?
Was that years?
Was that the writer
that was that started?
I don't know how it started.
I think it was Jesse.
I think it was the writing.
Suddenly, the writing,
you know, was the writing that
but then I think it
kind of
envisaged its way through the whole show.
You know,
I don't know if it was
something that was meant as a theme,
but it's become something. Yeah.
I mean, people ask me to come across
all the time.
You know, I remember
I remember I was doing a play.
I was playing LBJ to
the president, Lyndon
Johnson, President Lyndon Johnson.
I would come out of the show
and I'd come out after the performance
and there'd be there was a
and this was the first time I happened.
There was a young couple of them,
and she was about 17,
and her boyfriend
was probably about the same age.
And they had the device and they
and they came up to me and said, Mr.
Cox, can you please tell us to call?
And I thought,
the world truly is crazy
that really that really convinced me
that we're in such a mess.
So, sure,
I kind of hope that before
this interview is over, you'll say,
well, this is what is so tarnished yet
so many people want to be told,
we've got an actor.
It's easiest thing in the world to say.
Now, it's quite happily.
I'll tell you, I'll just go
But I have to say, I don't think of the
CNN studio they've ever
had said that word that often.
All right.
I want to
you share some fascinating insights
about acting in your book
that the key to good acting
is not to show the audience, but
to share with the audience
and let the audience discover.
This is your idea about coming forward.
Like we're we're
coconspirators in this effort
and allowing the audience that
intimacy with you, intimacy
with the characters.
And I think that's why Logan really
has become very successful, you know?
You know,
it's a kind of time and time
that you come to a role
suddenly that you've you know, you've
I've had a great career.
Don't get me wrong,
I have had the best career
that I can imagine.
I couldn't imagine any better.
But then you come to a role like that,
which is so kind of archetypal
in many ways,
and yet you've got to kind of deconstruct
the archetype
to be
who he is, what he is,
where he comes from.
And that's why when his son comes
with moral statements like your evil
well, the truth is,
yeah, we've seen a lot of
evil people in the world, but you go,
did they start off evil?
They did start off in that way.
How do you get to that point
where somebody regards you as evil?
where your your disappointment
in humanity has reached the And clearly,
that's the one thing that Logan
and I have in common,
because we're at an age
now where we feel Jesus.
Well,
sorry, I have to say what of life is.
You know what I'm absolutely up at?
As you say in the book, there are no big
or small parts
there are just short and long parts.
You you say do your job and move on.
And actors are desperately insecure.
Yeah, I do.
People in your business
line of work tend to inflate
or what it is you do for a living.
Oh, no.
I think we I mean,
that's a hard question that
we possibly do out of our own vanity.
Yeah.
Maybe we we over inflate it,
but I also think
I go back to what
the intention of acting is,
what the intention of the theater is.
And Shakespeare
says it better than anybody.
He talks
about holding the mirror up to nature.
And that's our job.
That's what we have to do.
And every aspect that we have to reflect
what's going on and and life and,
you know, the great actors
are the most human.
Like Tracy to me
is one of the great surprises.
Spencer Tracy is the greatest screen
actor of all time.
I can watch him endlessly.
He's also naughty, by the way.
But because I've just
I'm now getting his technique
because I've become an a Tracy watcher,
and but he's so gifted and he's so true.
He's always true.
Talking about the craft, you say that
voiceover work
is your passion.
Now, here you are doing with just
as committed,
just as effective as anything else.
A commercial for McDonald's.
Yeah. Oh, there you are.
You could count
how many sesame seeds
are on top of the hot
and deliciously juicy, quotable huh?
Or you could just eat the hottest,
juiciest quarter pounder.
Yet it's perfect.
Made perfect.
Bottom up, up
So I have two reasons.
A shark I never seen.
So.
First of all, you're very good.
I want to eat that hamburger.
You make me want to eat it.
But is there never a thought?
I'm Brian Cox. This is beneath.
Oh, no, no. I don't believe in a lot.
I'm an egalitarian, you know?
I know
this is what I loved about this country.
Unfortunately, it's not as egalitarian
as it supposed to be, but it's not.
But I.
That's what attracted me about America.
You know,
I don't believe that
anything is beneath me.
You know, I believe that it's, you know,
we follow.
I'm personally
calling and draw our wages.
You know, it's a mercenary calling.
And sometimes we play King Lear or Titus
Andronicus or Bock or Churchill,
you know, those great roles.
And then the opposite is
but Donald's and given to Caesar.
What is Caesar's?
You know,
I love doing, but I enjoy it
because it's funny
it's witty
and the
and the copywriters are
doing a great job.
It's it's one of the
what is things there are
and that's why I love doing it.
I love that challenge.
You grew up in Dundee, Scotland, in
in real poverty.
Your dad died
when you were eight years old.
Your mom had mental health issues
When you were 14,
you joined a repertory company
and sometimes you say
you would sleep in a little nook under
the sun.
Did all
of that
hardship help
make you the man you are today?
Or could you just as
soon have done
without the Charles Dickens childhood
your life was your life.
You know,
I mean,
to lose
one's dad
at the age of eight is awful for anybody
to have a mother
have a serious and nervous breakdowns
because of
she felt guilty,
because she felt
my dad was incredibly generous
and my mother's great cry
was charity begins at home.
So there was a conflict already in there.
But I the irony was,
Chris, the irony was I never felt it.
I didn't feel I was in a bad place.
I felt I was heartbroken,
but I didn't feel that I was
I just thought,
well, I've got to deal with it.
I've got to cope, you know?
I mean, my coping mechanism,
I had no idea existed
until all that happened to me.
And I just got on with it.
And my education was a disaster,
you know, but I knew what I wanted to do.
I always knew what I wanted to do.
I always knew I wanted to be an actor.
You have made it very clear
that when Logan Roy's story ends
your career doesn't end.
You say the only way you see this ending
is in a pine box. Yeah.
I mean, it's a stop on the highway.
It's been a great highway by the way,
but it's a stop.
It's an and it's a wonderful stop.
I don't.
And anyway, I would never regret it.
It's been a fantastic time.
I'm in one of the best time,
but I'm going on.
I'm going to direct my first movie,
which I'm doing, which is my love letter.
Well, our love letter,
the writer and I were both scotch.
It's a love letter to Scotland.
And then I'm going to do Bach and a play
about Bach written by a friend of mine.
And then in
January of 2024, I'm going to do a play
that I've wanted to do for years,
which is a long day's journey into night.
And I'm going to play James to Rome,
and I'm really looking forward to it.
I'm going to go back to the theater,
and I feel that
I need to get back to the theater
because I need to know
that those muscles
are still working or not.